[Music]
we're like right right in the prime spot
of summer any plans this weekend nothing
really out of the ordinary you well it's
the summer you know we're in the good
part as I said so I'm invited to three
different barbecues oh really
yeah are you up on your grill small talk
what do you mean no grill small talk the
fine art of standing next to someone on
a grill and you're talking to kill time
Andy I talk for a living so I don't
think I'll have any problem next to a
grill just chatting well we'll see when
you take the all right okay counting the
goal is for you to hit all seven
conversation points of a master grill
small talker in the allotted time no
problem I got this all right well you're
ready yeah go
growing out man huh you picked a perfect
day for it
yes the weather what are those Spencer
steaks man those marble up real nice oh
oh that's it gotta the meat good one
I see you went with a dry rub instead of
a marinade yeah
meat seasoning always a good choice you
know you know what I would have done I
would have soaked a handful of wood
chips and a red wine then place them in
a foil pouch and then put that on the
coals there's this company that's called
micronics yeah and they make the little
parts that go into the steering wheels
and self-driving cars it's a long play
but there were you I'd get in now
all the owning form stock did very nice
you see Bob's wife Karen and the two
piece I'm reading ready to write her a
thank-you note so where do you stand on
black lives matter that is not small
talk move on that's not us that's not
small talk subject move on you know
there's a possibility you can transmit
the Zika virus non-sexually Oh seriously
again not small talk people talk about
genocide but when it comes to killing
your own people
no one top Stalin oh my god Conan you're
really struggling I mean we're down two
seconds here you got to pick this up
nice choice on the Alpine IPA poppy with
hints of grapefruit
[Applause]
you